incredible I've never experienced this why doesn't
everyone talk about this movie all the
time this is why reaction videos were
made can't wait for you to sit like this well
let's see what would that look like hold on
I do need to kind of just test it for a second
okay but it's full short so we okay I don't think
that's a great look a it's it's a very suggested
what about this it does look very weird I think
you use it if I have to if you if you decide
to you're in shorts I am in shorts it'll be
the beginning of this video all right I'll just
declare that I'll say you for C citizens of the
reject Nation since orphan went over so well
with the audience we're immediately following
that up with orphan first kill of course rejoined
by Roxy stri who after looking at our videos over
the past year I will W the real rejects scream
Queen what yeah I didn't know you were going to
do that there you go I'd like to thank my dead
mom my dad I I think we should thank them too
all members of the dpcc dpcs yeah you know
me I'd like to thank this company for making
this shorts because they know that I can't
close my legs on the show for too long intro
complete but she was trying to say was cuz she'll
sit like this and it became a whole conversation
of like maybe today we got be like but you're
in shorts so you know all right I'm a SC leave a
like on the video be sure to subscribe click that
notification Bell tell us in the comments do you
like this one is it better than the last one leave
your thoughts down below thank you to prepper for
helping us set it down these highlights full link
through action watch long where you sink up with
your own copy of Orphan first kill available
for super sex re just cover our patreon page
John and I cover several things exclusiv over
there with highlights and watch Longs included
can't keep her legs closed so wow that was the
most unbelievable thing I've ever why it turn
into we'll just say you up a comment to protect
you and then you just double down said like
nope
I got every single prediction I had wrong
yeah for the first movie well get ready to
get it all right because it's a prequel so
might be a little more predictable did you
write this one also like the last
one mhm take credit for everyone's
material e w so you wrote Passion of Christ I
wrote Passion of Christ too Jesus Strikes Back
oh the font we don't know that much
about Ester that's the point of the
prequel I know we know about
the fire but that was a little
later Estonia where's that is that Russia
well we knew she was from Estonia but I I
want to say that it's not Russia
it's Estonia is that a different
country I want to say yes it's not a city
comment below something we could easily
Google I've never felt this dumb before why
I've never heard of Estonia Estonia is a real
like known place is it a country or a city I
think it's a country continent definitely not
a continent yeah sain Institute which is what
we were calling calling calling yes yes yes
do you know yeah hey mirroring the last one
remember she was watching from outside arms
up first movie started off like
a dream was a dream and there is
a dreamlike quality here welcome are you
ready for your first day do you leave far
somewhat but it's worth it always wanted
to use art to help people wonderful I was
hoping she said where she would live so we
would know yeah out here on this continent
Donia doer it's Lena she's not in the
room nobody can find her so get quick
Kenny Lo it whoa do you remember what they said
Esther's name was I think it who they just named
yeah this is a great day one on the job who's
Lena our most dangerous patient your predecessor
underestimated her and ignored the protocol
do not leave this room you will be safe here
and come back after we found her oh man I feel
like this one could be just a fun team Esther
movie She's definitely in there right for
sure oh yeah we see her in the background
what are we hearing hello there hello
there oh no does your mom or dad work
here it's crazy cuz she had to be two
years older shooting this one than the
first one right yeah that would make sense
based off of how time works oh she's going
to stab her with the pencil is that me wow
you cook that up quick I'm Anna what's your
name oh is she going to do it yeah
she's going to do it you're right
Lena oh no do your parents work here why
would you think that cuz you're and what
oh
no put it down put it down
now the people in the comments taught us
last time that Leonardo DiCaprio said if
they didn't cast this girl he was going to take
it to different Studios that she was like the
only one all the auditions they Poss could cast
yeah well he was trying to imprint so that way
when she turned a certain age he could finally
dat her somebody else in the comments wrote that
too she struggled so hard against
her restraints that she would bleed
severely much of Lena's early life
was spent doing whatever she could to
survive reactions are real there's no cutting 2
years ago this family took her in they fed her
Elena would simply steal whatever she could
and then disappear appear but this time well
she lives here now did they establish how
old she is here they said that she's 31 so
this is only just two years prior that is an
interesting timeline trajectory to do this two
years later and then only because she looks
so much older but it is what it is you know
it's not much they could have done about that
she's not still what an interesting child actor
role oh
what did she show her that
white she just knows how to trigger she stolen
yeah longer dadd a few minutes darling you Le
Me by heart little S no Daddy shle Temple I
know you by heart you're outside my heart and
that's where she got the idea I love Shirley
Temple ah so so the implication was to emulate
Shirley Temple hello dri you're on time on time
for what creep nature is developing delivering
packages oh my God that is disgusting he's
so creepy I want to do something nice for
you you can come in yeah yeah ew e this is
what what I'm saying I get she's 31 but you
don't think this is creepy what part what
did you think I would if I this of course
this is creepy Greg you don't think this is
assumption place it's weirdo into this you are
Greg I mean it's obvious he part of his
turn on is the fact that she looks really
young that's what I'm saying is the
creepy part or she going to get his
gun she going to bite him dad
has toen there it is there it
is see I'm kind of surprised by that because she
did want to hook up with an older guy right like
that's was the dream it wasn't just about hooking
up with an older guy it was about uh the element
of like the father and stuff yeah well he could
have been her daddy no he's Soo much of a too
weak oh [__] Esther's on a road trip I thought
it was just going to take place in here the
whole time but where at here in this Asylum but
maybe where and what a road trip oh um estabon
stonia whoa people in manal asylums are crazy she
did get scared just now we haven't seen her remote
much kind of looks like a Saw movie now
whoa that was a camera there was weird
yeah oh she here she's fast stealthy and
impossible to make out a silhouette behind a
door yeah it is so fuzzy yeah it looks a little
bit more like a Saw movie yeah that glow it
has somebody's going to come in so you think that
was her first kill the basion of the head oh yeah
I didn't think about it like that yeah it's a
pretty cool tracking shot though that they've been
doing confidence K do you want
some candy smart sticker sticker on
him
you have to give her the candy that's not
nice she will give her candy right
oh she's letting everyone go yeah
man save she has morals that's what we
call the save the cat Mo right there now
I can root for Esther as she murders I mean
I rooted for her for the tire tire last movie
you were te- master in a very different
way than I was oh no this is where drive
forward what are you doing out of the car what
are you doing I'm so sorry Anna hopefully the
police will find her before anyone else is hurt
not quite the start we had hoped for I'm sure this
job isn't for me really seems like a cakewalk
oh so Esther's in her car right that would be
really silly if Esther's just in there I'm for
it though that's got to be what it is right of
course to put this in like a prequel perspective
for Esther it really changes the kind of genre it
is like it's more of like a campy slasher
well because in the last movie it's the
mystery about who she is right wow so she's
about to get out of the trunk or what's up
B it yeah okay damn Roxy your predictions
are on point she did not bother to check
to see now if Esther was in your car now
that I'm not blinded by my my obsession
with the fact that as's a child I can actually
predict the movie or it's a fake out no it's
definitely not a fake out Esther popped out
obviously she's either under or she's coming
around no yeah yes oh Esther who are we going
to root for for Esther to like there's got to
be someone we and nobody's going to
be looking for her cuz she quit the
job kind of feels like a foreign
film for film a foreign film I was
going to say what you watching Craig very specific
taste Esther always knew how to play the
piano she just taking her identity
yeah
what a wild plan well now she has a house
honestly I would kill for a house too oh
Anna it usually takes only one jeez jeez she
said usually so I don't feel like that guy
was her first kill right and she got into
this place so she obviously killed before
I think first kill is just a title to uh make
us like watch a prequel yeah I'm just saying
Bo so you don't be frightened I'm please
you're lucky it was just a cop who showed
up where are your parents my parents are in
America what is your name my name is Esther
okay I'm going to drive you to America
okay we know where Connecticut is it is a
country let's go let's go
go is this not Esther no this is a
tall person yes Esther's known for her
height Julia Styles Save the Last Dance if
Roxy wasn't self-conscious about her skirt
she'd be doing her Save the Last Dance
pose right now for sure when I move you
move gunar works his tail off when he's
not studying he's fencing he's living
his life she wears the bow like Esther I
need you to be present Gunner needs you
oh sorry was I not at that match mr's not
coming back Alan ah every moment of every
day what a weird infiltration plan wouldn't a
DNA test say otherwise very quickly I mean I
don't think she's going to will she be convinced
it's their daughter or will they just randomly
adopt her Moscow Russia not Estonia different
country it's the first thing we're Googling
when we're done my mind always thinks Julia
Styles is 21 years oh yeah that's what I was
going to say the 21-year-old Kiron dunce is what
I always imagine a woman abducted her brought her
to Russia and passed her off as her own child
until Esther managed to escape what she needs
right now is our family be prepared for changes
4 years is a long time in the development of a
child oh the might just think she grew up a
little bit fortunately she looks a lot like
the missing child I know but she looks a lot
like her you probably Mis it's me it's Mommy
it's not my favorite line maybe that's because
I don't have a mom Greg rob it in why don't
you would you be able to know four years isn't
that long I mean you could be clouded by your
grief it's been so long since you've seen any
of us there's daddy this was one of charity
events they loaded your brother's probably
a foot taller oh there's mmup she's been
so good to us oh I can't wait to see her she
passed remember it's just the four of us now
yeah totally yeah she did say she's been so
good to us over there no it's just right back
over there that was kind of a misleading
way of saying [__] she took vodka with
her let the games begin get your head in the game
master you're going to smell the
v no Esther it's kind of like watching plot
points of Esther's plan play out from the
first movie but from her perspective this
time this movie is so creepy cuz now we know
you look like a little lady take this off
that's better it's less AER this is sorry
no I I'm sorry I this is such a weird dynamic
well cuz if you're her mom you're wondering
what the have happened to her for the last
like she was abducted yeah and then you were
told you got to keep a respectable you got
to be have boundaries yeah as she adjusts
I'm nervous all right big step was that
the dad in the photo in her uh yeah last
movie there has to be something like a
mole or like something like a scar this
is a cruel plan of hor I mean oh my
God it's like a similar thing of like
taking advantage of a grieving
family but even worse because
glad you're back me too how about we go home
yes like DNA test bro I mean would you care to
would that be your first thing yes your first
thing would be I need a DNA test or or would
you just go oh my God I would like I would
like to think that I would know if it wasn't
my child for four years it's not 14 years but
she I mean she looks enough alike though four
years though come on if I don't see you for
four years I'm going to be like I'm going to
need a DNA test if Roxy I was your kid bro
in four years would you develop an accent it
can okay but let me let me just run something
by you she could have stopped here like in just
sure yeah I just lived out of life inance we have
a lot of Christmases and birthdays to make up for
so let us know what you're into and you might get
it I like painting you were never interested in
painting before you learn a lot in child traffic
trafficking apparently you got really good at yeah
it's quite an educational experience here tomorrow
you're going to talk to Dr Seager well if you need
anything we right down the hall all right like
you're just going to leave her be I mean I don't
think they win parents of the Year award I I
can't even begin to understand like what how
you would yeah but it's not her bro yeah but they
don't know that I'm saying they should check her
ears check her fingers like there's no check her
ears what you like you this is somebody you bathed
you know where their bird I feel like there would
be a bit of an instinctual I feel like there' be
a bit of an intuitional feel like something off
where do you have a scar um I don't I think um my
body's perfect no my body perfect body B with a
six-pack welcome home well now you're certainly
not the little girl I once knew you have no IDE
bit I was adopt I mean abducted do you remember
what I told you when we first began our session
I told you if I ask any question questions that
make you uncomfortable we'll stop why was she in
therapy before they keep asking what happened to
me but I'm not ready to tell them about it and
that's perfectly fine I am hoping you'll talk
to me about it but only when you're ready think
that parent's going to die I think the parent's
going to die you want to play Sydney I think
Sydney wants to play with me hello I remember
you you remember me remember you how old's that
bird remember she said remember she's the one
with the parrot is what her mom style said to her
oh yes this is why you're here to pick up on the
details what are you writing I'm sorry it's okay
I'm sorry this kid's getting a lot from that
mirror that's a cool shot she seemed the
same as you remember different she she
has an accent now you asked that question
I did notice some inconsistencies Sydney
was a maau yet today she addressed this
bird as Sydney with complete confidence
to me it felt like a performance he hit me
and ripped my dress I want to go home we
reschedule
they have to do I already want an orphan 3 where
she's still alive somehow from the water yeah not
subtle at all you got to know how to take
photos of girls without them noticing what
happened to this actress she is so effing gooda
got Gunner for me would you what did you call me
Mike that's her sister oh [__] called her mortia
you said she looked like Wednesday Adams last time
is that Spanish or something your sister's
a trip man seriously dude my dad's right
there I don't care back to the bullying
older brother a rich family to take me in
and ask no questions I know God you
think we being in dpcs we' have the
opportunity what's the light for you don't
remember it's what your Papa's famous for
we should take a drink every time someone's
like you don't remember yeah yeah they're
using it a lot that's where she learned the
NightLight thing yeah I always try to fit so
much into one canvas you know so I resorted
to a a hidden layer so she's 10 now so she
was six this guy's going to go through some
serious heartbreak if he ever finds out oh
no I should have gotten rid of this who is that
there's no use delling on the past your home now
that's all that matters right there the guy taking
pictures the detective yeah but the detective
probably doesn't believe that that's where she's
really back I want to draw you I can I can do the
Thinker the way you were when you were looking at
that that's not a place I want to live anymore you
learned to paint while you were over there mhm
yes because I'm 31 so I'll see you at the Galla
tomorrow then okay it's for a good cause just
bring your checkbook and Jim it's for Pediatric
cancer for Christ's sake Maybe cancel every event
you've ever had because your daughter is home I'm
finished it's interesting because I I like
this Dynamic more with the dad
than I did in the last movie
already it's not going to be as easy
because he thinks you're blood daughter
you know Master her it's an obstacle though
you know Noe it's a challenge but if anyone
could overcome this challenge it's need you
not to go there right now Greg need you not
to go there es can do it that's private oh I'm
sorry I I was looking for my gold watch good
lie oh she's reading her old oh this
will help her mommy took me to hello
Mommy thank you Mommy I know Mommy she's
going to be able to say I remember when
we went to Wicked you know he book her
she's going to have to look up everything
that happens in Wicked This is delicious
mommy is something wrong no no I'm I'm
just wow she really is like a great she's unreal
yeah this is a police officer who helped us when
you on missing he's a friend I just uh came to
say welcome home eser is that the tagline of
the movie welcome home welcome home Esther Esther
did vanish from our little town and that remains a
concern I need to know if there's still a danger
I spoke to Dr Seager this morning a danger like
of under kidnappers she told me she's open to
a group discussion tomorrow morning your g is
tomorrow we'll do it the following day then it's
important you forgot to fill your glass but in
the last movie she remembered to get the soda can
this she learned her mistake she grew she oh oh
oh Esther no this is not the path is happening no
don't kill the the rat is she thinking of running
yeah no don't please don't she's not going to kill
the rat she loves the rat why would she love it
oh thank God why would she kill the
rat because she's crazy she is a
rat Oh no just check out what he's drawing it
might be you oh this is interesting because
she's she's actually like truly emotionally drawn
to him she goes back there's a there's like a oh
what she going to say to the there a twisted
tenderness that's going to form for that's
interesting the the part that's kind of lacking
for me is how like ver fora the the mom was like
phenomenal and I I feel like Julia Styles's
character is well she just doesn't seem to
care that much that she's home she doesn't
seem like a character to me you're coming of
course I'm coming get my wife I can deal with
a few Rich for you and what about Esther well
Gunner's here be fine right uh oh it's
crazy they got Den villanu to play the
dad are we communicating that's not
him oh yeah let's go through the Beats
oh my God those are amazing oh as's GNA
see it I know yeah let's go through the
beats that remind me of the other movie
yeah the other movie stuff
oh my god wow that is really
graphic she just close the door she ripped
her dress why didn't you close the door what
is with you neglectful ass parents and and
doing stuff oh my god do you know how much
I spent on this dress I think you can afford
another one no it's tonight you don't think
she owns another dress you have no idea
what it is to be a woman uh I can I can
imagine struggles we're off probably won't
be home till after midnight okay so don't
let her stay up too late copy that what
was he wearing so what are we going to do
we this is the world's worst brother I don't get
why he I feel like he would give a little bit of
a [__] yeah I know it it's sister yeah and he's
old enough it's not like he's eight it's not the
adopted sister I don't buy you as like you're
my missing my sister who's been missing for
four years like she's different all right she's
got an accent now she dresses like Lizzie bordon
it's so weird I hate you who's ly Bon some crazy
chick who killed her parents with an axe uh Hey
Esther that kid is a winner this is new your scene
go watch a movie go yourself oh team Esther he has
no idea what she's been through my parents aren't
here throughout mom's Gala just my luck having a
party he knew that the parents were going to
the gala he wanted to interrogate Esther why
don't I just tell my parents that you stop by
and we can just forget all about this mind if I
H hit the restroom before I go this kid sucks I
know he's awful like like and so awful he's not
believable what is she about to
do I feel like there's a hidden camera
in her room or like a bug or something
what year is this what does that matter
cameras hidden camera like they could
still have one right 2,000 I don't
know we don't see any cell phones so
let's hope the house is still standing I mean when
I was 16 I I nearly I nearly put the house down
foreshadowing ugly dress she going to a
funeral I see the notebook oh no F left
it there on purpose though isn't it just
a Bible no with the pictures and the notes
and stuff that she writes in it right or
at least later on there something like
egregiously terrible or something you know oh
we'll see it's pretty bad Greg it's a little
bad this is not good Greg s Institute
you would think with like this level of
wealth and investigation they'd be like be
on alert Russian police there what's about
to happen what's about to happen Greg what's
about to happen what's about to happen she's
going to take a shower no no no the guy's
dead in there the guy is dead you think
she would kill the detective here no Esther's
not in there though what do you think's going
to happen I don't know but nobody's in the
shower and it's running she she knows that
Esther's there this is bad Greg isn't this
his home yes we just saw that she had his
address yeah yeah she's going to murder him yes
well aren't you understanding Greg that's bad
fingerprints oh he took her prints
dude the DNA thing you wanted
creepy okay you heard that though bro so get up
do detectives just have like at home forensic
stuff I don't know cuz I just told you I
didn't know if they were webcam so what
year are we these came out in the early
2000s right or mid 2000s I the first one
was in 2009 but this takes place two th
two years before it's got to be early as
2007 oh my god Becky look at her butt who
the hell are you whoa whoa right in the
the how did you know that I'm not this sir her
mother doesn't even know she suspects yeah kid she
does what direction are we going down with this
this is very unexpected are you looking at so
let me get this straight you're a grown ass woman
and a wanted criminal that is beyond up I suddenly
very interested when gunar told me Donan came to
the house I knew I'd find you here you could have
robbed us blind and disappeared the second you had
a chance but you didn't all my criticism is about
who her character is suddenly went out the window
you'll never see me again that's exactly what I'm
afraid of we can't have Esther disappear twice now
can we did she didn't disappear there was nothing
that I could do for her what gunar he was always
way too rough with her that he just went too far
what was I supposed to do oh my God the only child
I had left over some sibling [__] that went too
far I loved my daughter but a mother protects
her family no matter what his family came over
on the Mayflower and built this country oh man
Allan matters when he got the news Esther was
alive the happiness on his face I had to make this
work clever clever I doesn't know what happened to
Esther and you are going to help me make sure that
he never does there is only one thing worse than
the death of a Child Jesus and that is a child
who is missing Esther's disappearance changed
Alan sadistic you are the answer this is nuts
man what a surprise so is is that Gunner with
her Esther's down there isn't she don't you say
her name what a Twist I know you you chose this
role and now you're going to play it even the
Gunner thing makes more sense now of his attitude
I'm like wow shocking and this is why she didn't
care when she's back you can be Esther for now or
you take the fall for this and get shipped back
to Estonia in handcuffs that's why she was cold
and suspicious oh man the mom was so detached I
was like what a weird performance damn this is now
damn movie damn movie it went from okay to awesome
oh [__] she fell off her bike I found her by the
side of the road come let's let's get warm mom I'm
so sorry stop oh my God s she's going to become
like a hero but make it look like an accident it's
too soon we need to think about this I I I love
this so much neither of us were expecting this so
for now we just keep an eye on her and the time is
right will end it incredible oh my God this is why
reaction videos were made was for [__] like this
it was so intense and I told you to shut up I was
like I can't I can't believe what we're watching
right now like that is so that was the most
unexpected thing never in a million years yeah
never but we picked up on all the things like why
is he being like this why is she it just seem like
repetitive Al some of the blot be felt repetitive
from the last movie but it was all like purposeful
to throw you off oh my God it wasn't lazy purpose
purpose unreal so so surprising our meeting with
Dr Seager is today a problem we wouldn't have
if you hadn't talked to the parrot Sydney was a
maau all MAA are parrots not all parrots are
MAA helping her Blendon what's a memory that
means a lot to you and to Esther there was uh
Christmas in Paris the summer in tusy I was six
we saw bed what else Esther wage Ranch and rode
horses mine was a pony named nugget and Daddy's
horse was called stretch so a lot of facts daddy
fell right over his head onto the ground he had
dir all over his face it even in his tell story
oh my God it's working it's working the mom and
her conning the psychologist together cuz all
we had heard in the next movie is that she had
fooled them there are people coming over
today just to see you does she have boobs
is that why they rap her always we are going
to pretend that pink is your favorite color
let's give them a story they want to believe
oh my God Julia Styles is so believable too
she's incred I've never experienced this ever
before just like wow this drastically switched
everything everyone talk about this movie all
the time is this the best movie ever made and
are your plans now young lady what are my plans
Mommy I am not letting you out of my sight but
the problem with the game is Esther can't
grow I know that's why they're going to kill
her who's in there is that Gunner brother yeah
are they going to start hooking up Greg I don't
know this movie completely surprised me you're
30 get out of my room now please it's my dead
sister's room you're not her and you never will
be okay you know I'm glad everything's out in
the open now cuz I'm done pretending like you
belong here you don't you crazy 1centers I own
you do that again and I'll kill you like
I killed Esther oh my God I love his gasp
one call from me and you're right back in that
goog you'd go down too why because of what the
illegal immigrant fugitive mental patient said
because I know where the body is [__] this is
America people like me matter and if you're
not Esther that just means Esther's missing
again mom has a problem with that I don't one
percenters is is he as bad of a person as she
is I think yes right yeah no I mean they're
they're worse they're worse than Esther in
every way not in every way he murdered his
sister and she covered the mom covered it
up well I made your favorite a I'm really
excited about going into the city tomorrow
and what a way to strip Esther away from
her power I've rediscovered the joy I once
felt doing what I love I feel like a kid again
you want to come I would love to well Esther
and I already have plans another time then
it's great that you're painting again Dad
wow what a phenomenal actress yeah may I be
excused you can eat upstairs it's okay honey
hey what's wrong making her eat she's going
to throw it against what is she going to oh
the rat oh then she's going to kill the rat
that's not going to kill the rat kill the rat
there's drugs in it the medicine remember
Julia Styles was pouring the medicine but
why would that kill the rat they were trying to
kill her this early I think Oh I thought maybe
it was like a slow burn but the rat is small
what happened down there I don't really like
mommy's cooking can you keep a secret I'm not
crazy about it either oh I like him so much I
don't oh there is like actual tender
bonding too I am so impressed with this
movie who is he he's very good too he
directed Dune prisoners stop doing that
we get to see beauty passion where others
don't even know to look I really like
that but she's like why isn't she
dead yet yeah so much paint yeah
oh my God and the and Julia ster get
so uncomfortable with this intimacy
cuz she knows it's like a 30-year-old woman
have a good night man that's really a child
actor we're watching right now her yeah I mean
I know she's an adult now but damn like very
believable are you so utterly delusional to think
that he would want you he would be as repulsed by
you as I suspect most men are oh my gosh she's
just in a prison again I'm going to go upstairs
and my husband Jesus Christ same girl tell them
how interesting like I thought they were going
to give Esther some like me imagine that like
this is so crazy Greg this is so multi layered
because I mean now we know how effed up she was
but this is part of why I thought we were going
to give Esther someone to victimize to make
a victim but like but instead they give her
someone to they gave her an enemy like that's so
such in in a way that's oh she knows the rat's
dead she's about to find out the rat's de Greg of
course the rat you know whoever came up with this
twist probably was like I'm the like I got it oh
it's too bad I got to burn this house down I'm
going to make my usual smoothie greek yogurt kale
flax seeds and lemon juice all this just cuz of
the dad I'm I'm not really that hungry I I'll am
it here no this is special just for Mommy I made
it for you man you thought I was rude for eser
before my God man I'm really rude for her now
delicious she is a dead rat in there you
okay I'm good yeah you got to got to hide
got to covered up get covered up I love
it it is a cat and mouse game of these
two DEA Woodley is a friend of mine Woodley's
the best art school in the country you're scary
good as can I show it to him thank you feel
for her yeah that's what I I was literally
thinking how normally something like this would
make you go all right they've I'm they beat the
whole Esther character to death at this point
but I'm like they've made her more interesting
how did they do that normally like you get rid
of the mystery and they're not as interesting
but I'm like now she's more interested oh
she's looking at them what she going to do
do push them in the tracks oh my God Greg
Greg Greg you're not going to succeed Greg
no oh my go you going P off Jesus
Christ what's for you going kid
she going to you yes she is what
happened our Arrangement is over hey
yeah [__] I mean he deserves to
die America open the goddamn door Esther don't
you I think the editors of this like cuz the movie
is directed different it's like more shock closer
more handheld um but the editing on this is really
great right like the way it's been ramping up what
happens from here she reported a stolen cart
like what's her game plan I thought she burns
the house down no I'm saying what happened like
right now her mom's reporting a a stolen car
all right and she what is her game plan from
here she's going to burn the house down right
now oh my God this little actress meme
it is she trying to look older or what is
she trying to I'm sorry was I driving too
fast you must be Esther yep it's been
reported I mean there's constant lying
and these outbursts of anger and sometimes
she even jokes about s and I don't think
she's really joking I love that Julia
Styles knew the role she signed up for
she's like I'm the villain in this one but
they're all the villains other than the dad
the dad is so nice nothing nothing is
worth having you in this house oh my
god oh no it's going to break daddy's heart
oh no oh my God the dad's going to walk
in nice is this where she burns the house
down just die you freak ouch nope nope
nope NOP oh no flashback where is she
I didn't mean to oh that's just brilliant it just
happened hi honey the police just
called me oh I know I'm oh no I'm
sorry keep eyes on her I'm on the train hold
on she got up it's right Esther it's right do
what you got to do go downstairs and finish
it no sweetie I swear everything is fine Esther
is here I was exhausted before filming I I wide
awake right now this movie is unbelievable
oh my God he's putting on his fening out
he's put on his out freak oh my God no you
should have kept it on I wish could like a
the actor negotiated his contract so that
his was seen during this I'm sure we could
figure something out you really believe that
what's behind her no me Nei [__] nice finish
it uhoh is the dad yeah no thank god
oh no oh she can but our Esther can
show Dad the Esther body what the Esther
who's like buried the real Esther yeah
yeah this is how the fire is going to
happen it's always funny to see
people movies like swinging like
that I feel like it be pretty easy
to stab someone when you got a
knife
Esther really earned getting into that orphanage
yeah look at what she struggled with this is the
thing too like dads are so non observant that he
whatever I both movies the dads are a little bit
naive this Dad especially my wife's a psycho but
is the dad going to die yeah you think he's going
to go into the house I I don't know actually
man D so Esther didn't technically Start the
Fire he will know who you are the deformed
freak who manipulated our grief murdered my
son why will he know cuz she's going to tell him
and tried to kill me until I did what had to be
done she's going to say Daddy help oh now
it's Esther on the outside of the house hiding
I think all the budget of the movie
went into the house and Julia Styles
yeah location location location
Greg and to the government of
Estonia whoa was this movie in 3D Papa be
like from a lot further away he would have
noticed the he just ran right the
in hey man he's trying to save his
family hold on I'm coming that's an
interesting yeah oh he goes to save
Esther first he can only save one
who's he going to save he obviously
is going to she's a grown woman
me lying your daddyy please help
me oh [__] oh she just slipped yeah she
said she can't hold on much longer Greg oh
no this poor guy just got back into painting
too is she going to push him no she likes
him yeah but she's I think she's worried he's
going to know Esther is going to give him the
truth oh she's going to do it you're right what
the I did this for you for
us I love you you're monst
Al oh you're right damn oh it was an accident
she should have shown him the truth about like
eser if I were to rewrite the movie which I know
people hate to here I think it like if she took
him to see where Esther's actual body is pro
that she's not Esther I know but it would also
reveal that the mom and the brother and the
some were like baths you know he could have
a little bit more of a twisted thing where he
lets her go I think so that's like they kind of
just we got to kill them off that's the Glory
of Love get adopted crazy God I love Flames
sure people who have experienced terrible
fires love that comment but Flames look so
beautiful mean you should present yourself as
like having a bit of a struggle yeah fire took
everything from Esther her home family syester
hasn't been through enough already abducted and
now an orphan orphan the title of the movie I've
reached out to a reputable adoption agency I'm
confident we'll find a home oh my God after
all who wouldn't want to adopt her look at
The Duality with the mirror that's cool oh my god
oh chills it's cheesy of a prequel ending that is
that is that is great look likey I mean I boom so
impressed that last half saved the [__] out of
this movie in ways I could not have fathomed and
Justified the first half next up a Wonderful Life
what a weird transition it works look Prime video
knows how to recommend yeah it's a wonderful life
if you like Oran first kill whoa Greg that was
like I honestly I'm I hope it's so I don't even
know what I said or didn't say that might be
the most silent I've ever been in a reaction
I this actually had me speechless at times uh yeah
I was I couldn't even I was shocked that was crazy
you know what else I'm shocked by people who buy
shirts from reject naations shop.com we shouldn't
be shocked those shirts are dope you should be
expecting that cuz they're awesome yeah keep
saying things because we have T-shirts flashing
up on screen while you're while you're talking and
they come in black and white and red and I mean
it's like we can't mislead people some of them
I have some it's true they come in all different
colors I have gray one too mhm and it's the best
way to support the channel love to see it and
also you're listening to us apple on Spotify we
just watched orphan first kill Greg joined with
the scream Queen Roxy ster over here that is me
okay number one where's Estonia is it a country
number two sure let's look I'm GNA look that on
my phone what is up with this little actress what
has she done since then okay those are the we'll
talk about the movie first Estonia it's a country
in Europe it's country it's a country it's an
actual country I was right about that thought it
was a city in Russia yep okay okay okay I feel I
feel better about myself right now okay number two
can you please tell me what this little actress
does fine I will look that up right now before
we actually talk about the actual movie itself
well it's relevant to the movie because she's the
star of the movie and this like I've never seen I
she might be the best child actress I've ever seen
my life Greg yeah because she has to like Isabelle
Ferman she has to play and um an adult pretending
to be a kid and she she just seems like a like
a real person at the same time like she doesn't
seem like a child pretending to be an adult you
know oh look no nor does she come across like
an overly precocious kid or something like that
you have to use it I'm going to look this up real
Qui I know how to look up stuff taking way longer
than I thought it's oh my God Ro just good thing
you're going to go watch found her so she's done
you no idea you don't what you're talking about I
got it right I forgot you guys have told me about
The Hunger Games that she was clove you guys told
me in the comments that she did some kind of knife
throwing thing I don't remember her but this girl
should book everything damn she's probably too
old now to do like an orphan three no she did
an orphan 3 there's no orphan 3 in development
there's an orphan 3 in development I don't know
you know how IMDb works sometimes sometimes they
be putting [__] in development that's not
actually in development is there an orphan 3
oh my God Roxy if we can get a final destination
6 and an orphan 3 oh my God God we are sitting
oh my God yes it's in development but in what way
is it in development from December 2023 it's been
in development wow wow this girl is 26 years old
now anyway do that sh wow yeah like okay if you
for some reason you skip the Rea every once in a
while a movie comes along like I really love the
first movie yeah me too I I think like the first
movie is a is a better movie way uh just in like
terms of like an actual the the the structure the
overall execution like the way it's directed and
the writing like the like actual writing of itself
like it's not Flawless there's definitely flaw in
it but you know like the surprises that they had
here in in that last one of like the whole time we
were like what is up with and that that emotional
back and forth we were having that I think a lot
of the audience will debate with in that first
movie is part of what makes that first one so
compelling it is like I don't know I kind of like
her and you're like she's traumatized I'm like I
don't know I feel she's kind of a suspicious
little little girl like that whole mystery
surounding her but on a sequel SL prequel level
a territory horror films often dive into this is
one of the most impressive ones to me completely
because I think that they really knew they had
us they knew in that moment everything's going to
make sense and it was like such a generic script
before then that was almost annoying to the point
where you and I are just like Su with the mom and
the the brother they're not even I'm like she's
not looking for birth marks why is he beinging
such a dick he doesn't even care all of it wasn't
making sense but the dad was being so loving I was
like what what is this that twist made all
that that first and second act or whenever
it came through the first half makes sense and
just so I think that this is a better movie I
think this is better than the first one I loved
the first one but to me this did something that
it's so rare for a movie to do to me and that
shocked me but not for shock effect like truly
brilliant writing so good I think though it needs
the first one because what the movie did in such
a self-aware way was know that it's being a sequel
prequel because the first half of it is doing like
like all the [__] that you see in like prequel
sequel stuff like yeah this this beat reminds me
of the last movie this one reminds me of the last
oh it's like the last movie but a little different
here uh they're kind of flipping the dynamic a
little bit and they and they have you they they
pretty much tell you at the beginning like yeah
this is going to be uh Esther Unleashed that's
what this film's going to be oh she's going she's
adoped into the house or we're watching the same
movie we're just watching the same movie uh but
with some different stuff and but but then once
Julia Styles shows up shooting the guy instantly
you're like ah that wasn't what I was expecting to
happen what's going on and yeah I think the what
a scene that is I think in like a like that kind
of grungy aggressive way the you've seen the Saw
movies right yeah not all of them but most of them
but you know how they this has kind of those Saw
movie flare to me where it's a little bit more low
lit and uh more close up a little a little grung
a little like meaner in its display whereas the
first one looked a little like prettier there's
like a little meaner and I love the I love a good
Flo have you seen the Devil's Rejects no okay
won't spoil it well anyway I the Real's rejects
actually the title was inspired from that movie um
I love a Flippo where you're watching protagonist
you're you're where you're watching the villain as
the main character and then suddenly you're like
oh [__] now I really care about the villain
and not in a way I was expecting because they
gave them a villain where they make things really
multiat because you're like but Esther's still
technically doing something wrong you know like
what she's doing was is bad but now I feel bad for
her and and the way they flip the power Dynamic
where she's back to being is essenti imprisoned
and and forced to do things that she doesn't
want to do I thought was yeah there's so many
things about this that I absolutely love though
yeah yeah I I think that the first one did a
great job like you're talking about is keeping us
guessing like you felt one way I felt another I'm
sure audiences are split about how they're feeling
what's happening most people probably with you on
that one like okay something's really wrong with
her but you're not sure what the whole time and
you know you don't know you know you don't know
what's under the the ribbon on her neck you know
you don't know what's under her wrists you know
you don't know enough about Esther this movie
convinces you you know everything and so you feel
confident like oh I know what I'm watching unlike
the last movie I had no idea I keep guessing this
movie is like oh no you now know her so you know
what's up so I wasn't looking for something like
a Twist I was thinking yeah now I know her I know
this movie so I'm in which is why when they do
the bait and switch and hit you with that scene
with the mom coming in and then shooting the guy
you're just like what yeah you guys just told me I
knew what was going on and I did not know what
was going on and it wasn't a like oh we're in
the Final Act it it was like the last half of the
movie which which I love so much because I I feel
like a lot of movies might have just made similar
how the last movie gives you that reveal like 20
minutes before it ends this movie doesn't do that
they they have their midpoint is just like all
right just when you think you know what this movie
is nope you're wrong so I thought it's smart and
and I think for Esther too like the I was saying
during the reaction of like the this character is
someone where a big part of what made her work
so much in the last movie was the the you know
the WTF surrounding her like who is this person
exactly like we know something's up with her but
who is she and then they tell you so you think
that like by pulling back the mirror and and
letting you hang out with her as the protagonist
and her perspective that it would actually dilute
her character but it just made her so much more
interesting and and her backstory more intriguing
and and it is it does make for a good companion
piece on to the to the to the prior movie yeah
what a perfect onew punch yeah the first movie
was great and I for me this movie was just as
great if not better equally built on that but
they're so different and a lot of sequels just
are the the original I guess it was a prequel
not a sequel but a lot of the second movie to
come out is just given us it in a little variety
of it and this was like actually we're going to
do something totally different cuz some people out
there be effed up too yeah not just Esther so good
great casting Julia Styles too man she awesome I
thought you was like man she's so boring and then
sudden I'm like who you're like you're creepy
as hell woman that son too he could definitely
be in any of these teen drama shows where you're
just the the rich prick I'm into this I'm so into
this I would love an orphan 3 I don't know how
they would do it somehow I feel like they would
find a way to pull off I feel like the last movie
had a bigger budget you had DiCaprio producing
it you had I don't think he produced this one and
like this felt like lower budget where so I think
like they were able to do like cooler shots like
the car sequence with the daughters in the in the
car in the last movie so I think they were able
to do like cooler looking sequences um but for
what this places in terms of like squel prequel
it is it is a wildly impressive uh installment I
got know the Rotten Tomato score can we look that
up yeah for both of them yeah yeah I don't know I
don't know for any of them actually let's find out
yeah I'm curious about the Rotten Tomato score I'd
also would be curious about the budget or are you
kidding me orphan is a 58 waack sauce and even the
audience score of 63 that's weak bro ah but this
was like at I mean I feel like horror movies have
a lot more respect now there's a time where it's
like oh your horror screw you and I thought the
last movie was a little this is higher with the
audience not as many people voted but damn this
higher on critics yeah quite a bit 71 yep because
that was just brilliant what they did yeah see I
think what they did um here which I thought was
an improvement was there W I felt that they were
self-aware unlike the last one where I was kind
of laughing at it this movie genuinely felt like
really self-aware I'm back and forth I'm back and
forth there are things about it where I'm like I
like I like certain parts of the the specifically
the directing and cinematography a little bit more
in the first one yeah I I like that too but in
terms of like a just an experience I think I
like my experience with this one more did orphan
first kill come out on Paramount plus might have
been some Paramount plus yeah didn't feel as big
of a movie what year was it uh the release date
was 2022 did it just come out last year wait look
up when I thought the first one came out in 2009
oh man we were way wrong people have probably
playing Common Police with us the whole time
oh damn so she was she still looks that young
we were here the whole time 13 year age Gap we
were here the whole time sounding like being like
Oh the most fil this just like two years after oh
my God damn we were way off well then she looked
amazing that's incredible like oh they put a lot
of powder and they did a lot of wow we just got
to see that's weird at like events and stuff she
looks like in her 20s how were they able to do
that I mean maybe this came out last effing year
must have something to do with her height because
yeah she like definitely looks like she's in her
20s and like these actual events and stuff wow
she's 26 but so last year she must have been 25
was how do they do that well let's look what she
looks like in the first movie oh she definitely
looked a lot younger she did look a lot younger
yeah but I said that a few times she looked a
lot younger but not in 13 years the performance
she was giving yes uh yeah well that makes it
even better our whole experience like dude this
child actor's insane she's still a great she's
still a great actress this wow do what she had
done 13 years prior that's hard too she had to
circle back to 13 years experience just keeps
getting more Amplified holy [__] oh my go cuz
she still looks like a a little kid she she still
looks like really really young wow but damn yeah
she does look like an adult and like actual
you know adult stuff even so no wonder so was
a straight to Paramount plus movie was it that's
what it looks like last thing we got to look up
then we got to get you out of here got you got
a place to go wow Greg this is the movie that
twists and terms until we can't even wow orphan
first kill theatrical release it might have just
been a straight to Paramount plus movie it was
simultaneously released damn that was a blast
okay whoa all right so we have that how did they
do that we have this movie okay man we we can get
orphan 3 and Final Destination 6 possibly we're
like how are they going to do orphan 3 now oh
cuz they did this one last year bro duh yeah they
got to do orphan 3 I know yeah we were like it's
been too long and she probably aged up too much oh
[__] wow that totally affected our our viewing
experience didn't it we were just like what I'm
glad I didn't know and it would also make sense
why they would have a lower budget after that many
years for sure cuz it wasn't like we got to follow
this up right away also I was thinking about that
during the movie and I was almost going to say wow
it's so weird because Julia Styles looks exactly
the same I I almost said that like four times and
I was just like don't say that Roxy because it's
been over a decade wow that is shocking okay cuz
I'm like what's this guy done since what's the
dad I'm like that's crazy they're all so good
why aren't they working since in 10 years oh my
God yeah it's true all right last thing to look
up last thing who's the dad that's the last
thing I want who's your daddy uh I'm DPC boom
bring it back feel bad for us but we're going to
act like you should have feel bad um orphan no
mouse you're right this is a shitty Mouse people
people complain about this mouse and it's true
it is a really bad M really that's Alfred Molina
there that is not him okay Canadian actor keeps
scrolling he went to Princeton cool cool I said
I thought he was in a show handmade's tail that's
the show he's in he's as sh him Isel okay dope
yep dope stuff dope stuff that makes sense all
righty guys well what did you guys think about
orphan first kill leave your thoughts down below
were you as shock as we wow that is I was like
if they don't say they're shock they're liars
I'm sorry if you if you didn't see that before
and you aren't surprised then you are a bace
liar I was like I am genuinely GL can you imagine
watching this without a camera pointed at i' been
like oh now I got to communicate that experience
to people not the same thing um that was crazy
that was crazy uh leave your thoughts down below
leave a like get a shirt and um follow Roxy and
let us know what else we should watch trolls what
yeah horror movies and the trolls franchise it's
all I got for Roxy guys sorry that we need
other movies for you uh did you do the help
I did do that didn't do that yet did I no that
went up okay did I film that all righty see you
guys